[Music]  this is no 4th of july  this is the national pyrotechnic  festival in tultepec mexico  [Music]  each year the city throws the pamplonata  pyrotechnica or national pyrotechnic  festival for nine days in march to  celebrate the feast of john of god the  patron saint of firework makers  [Music]  local families businesses and firework  factories build enormous bull shaped  floats out of paper mache called toritos  the construction of which can take  months the exterior of these floats are  completely covered with decorations and  fireworks this is all in preparation for  the festival's most popular event the  burning of the bulls  the bulls are paraded through the town  and brought into the square in front of  crowds chanting fuego or fire  a courageous soul is then sent in to  light up each float  as the bulls are pulled through the  fearless crowd the fireworks illuminate  the town and the party rages on into the  night  [Music]  you